I've been working through how you'd
write super simplistic read it write
rules using true and false.
But that's kind of useless in the
shopping list plus plus world where we
want to read it write based
off of who's logged in.
>> Yes, connecting your authorization
to your authentication.
That should be very easy your
developer just needs to know a bit
about a few extra variables here,
let me show you.
>> As you know Firebase provides helpful
variables that you can use in your
rules.
You've already learned about
two of these, data and
newData, which are essentially variables
that you can use in your JSON Rules for
the previous state of the data and
the new state of the data.
In addition, you have access to root,
now and auth.
Root is a variable that represents
a rules data snapshot, much like data or
new data, but
it's of the root Node for your data.
Now is a variable,
that stores the timestamp, representing
the exact time on the server.
You can use it to write
rules to check for
things like whether the timestamp is
before or after the current time.
For example, the following rule could be
used to check that somebody isn't trying
to write a timestamp
that is in the future.
And one of the most important
variables is the auth variable,
this variable has two
pieces of information.
The provider and the uid of the user,
if they're logged in,
if the user is not logged in,
the auth variable is equal to no.
This variable allows you to check
whether someone is logged in and
is a specific user.
A lot of the permissions
to edit lists and
shopping list items, dealt with
who the logged in user was for
any rules related to who the user is
you'll need to use the auth variable.
Beyond representing dynamic keys,
wildcard variables are also available to
you in the rules themselves, they take
on the value of the key that they match.
So if you had a messaging app that
had lists of messages a user posted,
this would allow you to write rules
that compare the dynamic key of
an object with the value
of one of its children.
Here we're checking that the user
ID property of a message matches
the user ID that it's listed under.
If you learn to use
these simple variables,
writing your read-write
rules will be easy as pie.